je ne rentre pas la vaccination
obligatoire pour tous renseignements
mesures qui pourraient être prises pour
tenter d'endiguer définitivement
l'épidémie de coronavirus à la une il ya
aussi la cinquième vague qu'ovide si on
force l'idée de rendre le vaccin
obligatoire fait énormément débat à
travers l'europe cette option est de
plus en plus envisagé comme l'a confié
ours ulla von der leyen présidente de la
commission européenne lors d'une
conférence hier au monde nous pouvons
encourager et potentiellement penser à
la vaccination obligatoire au sein de
l'union européenne l'autriche a déjà
annoncé qu'une vaccination complète
serait obligatoire pour tous ses
habitants à partir de février 2022 on
s'interroge sur les éventuelles
restrictions qui pourrait arriver en
france du côté de l'autriche larron sert
très sérieusement dans d'autres pays
pourrait rapidement clencher le pas
comme l'allemagne ou la grèce qui a déjà
imposé la vaccination où plus de 60 ans
mais la france pourrait-elle suivre le
même modèle si certains y sont
favorables il faut rendre la vaccination
obligatoire d'autres dénoncent une
attaque cruelle des libertés je pense
que le vaccin est une protection
personnelle
et vous et beaucoup contre la
vaccination obligatoire
je sens que le débat va être chaud
bouillant chaud patate à ils ont mis
leurs petites pancartes et la face à
face ce soir on a deux amis de la
famille tes pmp
mangold le restaurateur face à l'autre
citoyen engagé olive olive et je crois
savoir les garçons que c'est la première
fois que vous débattez alors que vous
êtes tous les deux des habitués du
plateau mais la première fois que vous
débattez l'un face à l'autre et que vous
êtes chauds bouillants tous les deux on
va marquer une courte pause et on
revient pour le débat sur la vaccination
obligatoire point d'interrogation a tout
de suite
[Applaudissements]
mais ed
touche pas à mon poste avec tdm ddm des
programmes sur mesure pour un corps sur
mesure training day est max points comme
[Musique]
pour soyez vous même en suivant votre
programme avec valaige
[Musique]
ses camarades
ma les temps
n'ayons pas
[Musique]
mal
m
bon j'en peux plus de me faire massacrer
à chaque fois c'est quoi cet ordi qui
rament tout le temps je pose plus dans
ces conditions optez pour la gamme
légion de lenovo sur cdiscount
[Musique]
vous les copains je ne vous oublierai
jamais nous
et nos peines et aux joueurs
tous ensemble
sauf à l'arrivée
ténue que les meilleurs gagnent gagner
des bons à parier en jouant au quinté
plus du 4 au 11 décembre à partir de
midi
un vrai spéciaux l'italienne s'il vous
plaît vous voulez dire un espresso
l'avatar semblait parler m dos
l'espresso à l'idonnière pour ceux qui
apprécient le savoir terrain gras mon
cap sud découvrez la batteuse à espresso
maestro les nouvelles capsules lavazza
en aluminium notre en carbone lavazza
bien plus qu italien
après cette vague en paquet sur ce coup
mais
mais au
fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait trop en tout cas ce qu'on
s'engage avec vous que les associations
et cette année pendant la croissance en
europe et des mines
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça c'est olivier qui s'est assuré celle
olivia science en quelques clics et ça
c'est encore olivier satisfait de
l'olivier assurances 96 % de nos clients
après un sinistre et ça c'est olivier
ravi de ne savoir élu service client de
l'année faites comme olivier
choisissez-le olivia science
la vie est meilleure quand votre chats
stérilisés reste agile et maintient son
poids idéal avec ultima stériliser des
recettes produites en france à partir
d'ingrédients de haute qualité ultime
partageons une vie meilleure
je dis bien sûr alex cool
tu peut jardiner bricoler entretien à
voitures nettoyer ta terrasse et bien
plus encore et tous ces outils
fonctionnent avec une seule et même
patrie je
les ramènerais je sais pour chaque
projet il y à un ryobi pour noël jusqu'à
40 euros remboursés sur une sélection
d'outils découvrir magasin nos offres
ryobi à prix cadeau
dans le confinement j'ai redécouvert mon
quartier j'ai vraiment apprécié le calme
de cette circulation apaisée
je suis vraiment content de voir les
vélos cargo s'intègre parfaitement dans
le paysage urbain d'aujourd'hui et de
demain il a démarré tout petits avec
seulement deux vélos depuis on a grandi
en se développe aujourd'hui dans
plusieurs centres villes de france à
colmar montpellier rouen strasbourg
paris le développement durable c'est une
course de fond et je sens vraiment qu'on
va dans la bonne direction
quelle équipe remportera le match
réponse de voir un prono pour ce soir 2
0 moi je pensais
[Musique]
alors je parie sur quoi ce monster
unibet parier sur l'api numéro un
[Musique]
ferrero rocher
laissez vous guider par sa magie
une magie né de la rencontre des plus
délicieuse sensation
crowcon fond d'un croustillant ferrero
rocher créateur de magie et laissez vous
surprendre par la magie du chocolat noir
avec ferrero rocher origins
chez domino depuis 60 ans nous formons
nos équipiers à transporter vos pizzas
bien protégés et en toute sécurité pour
qu'elles restent chaudes et appétissante
livrer des pizzas ça ne s'improvise pas
minos et découvrez notre programme de
fidélité des 60 points on vous offre une
pizza
pour les fêtes de fin d'année la maison
thiriez vous a préparé une surprise
glaces disponibles en magasin que les
cales pollet livraison de missiles et
thiriez point corps
maison terrienne seul le bon crée du
bonheur
bonjour le temps est agitée dans la
gorge d'alice on observe une vague
d'irritation au sud et une pluie de
pilotes dès les premiers signes d'un mal
de gorge peu intense et sans fièvre
l'isoprène maux de gorge c'est il périt
d'ignobles lysozyme combat l'infection
localement et soulage la gorge l'iso pas
une mode gorge de tous temps avec votre
gorge tout médicament peut exposer à des
risques parlez-en à votre pharmacien
[Musique]
touche pas à mon poste avec tes des âmes
ddm des programmes sur mesure pour un
corps sur mesure koenig et nax points
comme
[Musique]
soyez vous même en suivant votre
programme avec valaige
[Applaudissements]
oh
au choix
juste un an pupille pas en train de
parler de la vaccination obligatoire
autant vous dire que s'il ya bien un
sujet qu'il faut pas aborder à noël pour
pas se mettre la dette sur la tronche ça
va être la vaccination est le co vide
mais nous on en parle parce qu'on parle
de tout dans touche pas à mon poste et
surtout des sujets qu'il faut mettre sur
la table justement la vaccination
obligatoire est ce que vous êtes pour
est ce que vous êtes contre déjà il ya
certains pays européens qui commencent à
dire il faut y aller alors en autriche
et la situation est assez catastrophique
toute la population a été récemment
reconfirmer le chancelier a annoncé une
obligation vaccinale
1er février prochain premier pays
d'europe à faire ce choix bon en
autriche il ya seulement 25% de la
population qui est complètement vaccinés
concrètement face à face il y a d'un
côté notre restaurateur qu'on connaît
bien stéphane manigold est de notre côté
notre citoyen engagé olivo libre les
amis vous les pancartes sont très
contrastés il ya du tour il ya du contre
on est on à combien de pour là on est de
3 4 5 pour et 2 4 et 4 contres donc
c'est vraiment moi moitié moitié on va
démarrer par part vous stéphane qu'est
ce que vous en pensez vous le
restaurateur est ce qu'il faut rendre la
vaccination obligatoire alors aux led et
restaurateurs et chefs d'entreprise il
m'arrive aussi d'être un citoyen engagé
mais engagée sur le fond ça commence à
laisser
les sujets de fond il le sait je pense
qu'il a dû décortiquer certaines de mes
interventions donc on va on va pouvoir y
changer là dessus moi je suis pour je
vous suis complète les mesures et oui je
vais vous dire c'est que ça veut dire
quoi pourrait mesurer pourrait mesurer
parce que si demain emmanuel macron mais
la vaccination obligatoire
vous avez des personnages comme monsieur
euro olivier qui vont aller dans la rue
manifester vouloir tout casser en
réalité et pas les leur donner raison il
peut aller dans la rue sans pu casser il
a le droit aussi de diarrhée oui
peut-être ce serait ce serait un doux
veut voyez qu'on pourrait faire pour
cette fin d'année j'espère qu'elle
insulte par la grâce et un moment quelle
insulte mais vous êtes vous citoyens qui
manifestent sont des casseurs bravo
monsieur vous donner image et c'est
parce que ici c'est ce que non vous
j'assure que si vous n'êtes pas
l'ensemble des jacks et n'aurait pas vu
comment je suis suivi par les médias si
j'étais un casseur ça ferait longtemps
que je serai en prison monsieur métais
dimanche soir vous allez manifester avec
des vies jamais rien passé parce que
justement c'est le moyen de pacifistes
une chose tout le monde juste une chose
vous n'allez pas faire noël ensemble en
fait
tu contention
c'est le grand pardon sait pas encore de
quoi qu'il faut pardonner à tout le
monde l'avait c'est vrai y paraît non
mais dans la réalité il faut des mesures
plus fortes je crois qu'on n'est 87% à
fait à avoir fait le choix
notre choix de vivre différemment que le
choix que monsieur souhaite imposer de
façon très minoritaires au fond parce
qu'il fait quelques lives il a lu deux
trois trucs sur facebook et donc il
assène ses vérités sur l'attaqué mais
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas dire aussi il
faut de la pédagogie plutôt que de
l'obligation pour ceux qui décident
aujourd'hui il ya des variantes de
variants de variants parce qu'on
n'arrête pas de faire de la pédagogie
avec des gens qui ne veulent rien
entendre
87% défense ont fait le choix de
vacciner eh bien demain moi se joue lire
hier le fond de ma pensée c'est qu'au
fond il a fait le choix d'être libre de
son corps ici et bien confie non celles
et ceux qui ont fait un choix vous êtes
comme comme l'autriche il faut le faire
il faut confirmer que les ions de
dictature salle et on vaccine pourquoi
la punition collective
doit-elle revenir au nom de quoi celles
et ceux qui ont fait le choix de se
vacciner de vivre d'être joyeux tout
simplement parce qu'au fond ce sont des
gens très bonne histoire qu'on comprenne
et nous avons fait le choix de vivre
juste vivre la vraie la liberté stéphane
juste pour qu'on comprenne vous vouliez
vous vous dites allons au bout et on ne
confine les non vaccinés non j'avais dit
qu'on confine on met des restrictions à
partir de 21h un couvre-feu moi je ne
souhaite pas que demain puisque c'est ce
qui devrait en tout cas c'est sur la
table je souhaite pas que la punition
collective reviennent 87% des français
et des françaises ont fait un autre
joueur et pourrait bien réaliser chez
vous aurez bonne forme et et non va
continuer 87 % des français ont fait le
choix de se vacciner je vous rappelle
que je suis pour la liberté vaccinale et
je ne suis pas si je suis pas un anti
works a maintenant parce que vous avez
c'est d'instrumentaliser quand même les
choses
87 % des français sont vaccinés tous les
jours cinquante mille contaminés on est
d'accord là dessus avait des chiffres
d'aujourd'hui c'est bien les chiffres
qu'on a aujourd'hui
en même temps est-ce que c'est
d'acheminer le développement 150000
contaminé jour vacciner des vaccinés qui
peuvent attraper le virus et oui donné
le virus et faire des formes grande
accord est génial mais c'est attendre à
continuer dans la norme mais je vous ai
laissé finir on va finir des des
hôpitaux on est en train de re déclenché
les plans blancs vous savez qui est en
réanimation aujourd'hui est ce que vous
savez qui est la majorité des personnes
qui sont en réanimation aujourd'hui
motive nom maxime élever
les enfants les infos sur sa ligne non
c'est pas mérité même si ce matin si
vous voulez je vous le soft vous le
voulez démarrer ils seraient excédés
raison c'est ce matin lci ce matin nous
dit que la tendance est en train de
s'inverser
il serait temps que les médias chinois
geely adorait le service est né à tout
le monde évoque 6 mais tout le monde est
en train de dire à 87% de la population
que le hockey il en vérité à travers des
spots publicitaires dès que vous leur
avez dit allez vous vacciner pour vous
protéger pour plus faire de formes
graves et ces gens l'ont mené au niveau
livre on imagine alors la vérité finit
non justin ce n'est pas lui rentrait pas
il est investi tiens je vais vous dire
quelque chose on fait quoi et c'est
triste et c'est triste mais en train
vacciner 1 en vacciner le non vaccinés a
mentionné je vais vous dire ivoire
profané pas c'est
quelqu'un qui est vacciné aujourd'hui ne
se teste pas il peut transmettre le
virus et peut contaminer les belles
images et une chaise de callao lima lim
au niveau livre juste une chose ça veut
dire que vous avez en démarrer en
préambule en dix ans je ne suis pas anti
vaccins mais la rédaction ne sert à rien
je dis pas qui sert à rien je dis
absolument pas ça je dis juste que
aujourd'hui on a annoncé pendant des
mois et des mois que ce vaccin protège à
95% on voit aujourd'hui que c'est
complètement faux donc concrètement vous
êtes montre la vaccination obligatoire
valérie germain joliette contre la
vaccination obligatoire alors je tiens
je vais faire un petit tour de table des
maîtres de meetic
pour avoir leurs sentiments
évidemment contre la vaccination
obligatoire d'autant plus qu'aujourd'hui
on a le droit on est en droit
aujourd'hui de penser de dire que ce
vaccin il ne sert à rien et personne
mais c'est vrai on a des personnes
doublement vaccinés qui attrape et
qu'ils transmettent locaux vides oui la
réponse et qui ne font pas de forme
grave d'accord mais les réfrigérants
s'il est d'accord les cieux pam qui
augmente de jour en jour dans de
nombreux pays sont comme si la situation
est que ces extraits étaient extrêmement
grave donc concrètement on a des gens
qui se sont fait vacciner sous la
contrainte par exemple pour partir à
noël et qui vont se retrouver à ne pas
pouvoir partir à noël donc moi j'appelle
ça une arnaque c'est une arnaque et lui
pour terminer monsieur vous avez dit
tout à l'heure qu'il fallait augmenter
les mesures d'avoir des mesures encore
plus fermes pour les non vaccinés mais
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire voulait
les mettre en prison ne peuvent plus
travailler que je dis c'est un média qui
fait baisser les affaires j'entends je
vous ai connues plus mesuré et moi mais
il a déjà changé un oui mais comment
vous les nommez roman vous l'algérie
at-on qui aimait la vie jamais sortir
vous allez faire la fête et continuez
vous pouvez oui mais comment vous pouvez
un charognard un discours ou au fond le
projet de vie de ce que propose aux
libéraux c'est l'enfermement c'est la
dictature c'est un vol en fait que vous
vous proposez c'est un aller sans retour
pour la corée du nord voilà ce que vous
proposez mon père
me dit qu'il n'a pas mesuré mais vous ne
vous êtes pas déconner au lit ce que je
vous souhaite à vous et sans délai les
gens qui vous regardent la police et
honte avait plein de monde a évolué vers
non mais sincèrement on te sent sa gamme
contient
ses 17 ans est bien là dessus et on
parlera de vaccination des enfants ça
c'est je tiens on va en parler en bas
parce que je vais votre vin c'est moi
qui décide sur nous
je sais vous allez l'aimer comme
synchrone à
l'abattoir faut que tout le monde soit
au courant quand on est quand on aura
ouvert la vaccination à partir de 5 ans
chose qui est fait puisque ça a été
annoncé ce matin pour le mois de janvier
et bah si on passe là bas tu n'entres
annoncé la coordination pour les ans
pour les engrais les 5 10 ans l'a
annoncé ce matin par le ministre a oui
mais ça veut dire
quoi et ben on va enlever l'autorité le
monde et on sera obligé de vacciner vous
répète pour la vaccination des mois je
vais vous répondre alors déjà je suis
pour la liberté en tant que père de
choisir pour mes enfants et basse et
moins jeunes il y a à priori autour de
ce plateau et des téléspectateurs qui
sont des parents responsables et qu'ils
peuvent voir leur projet si vous n'êtes
pas aimé laissez-moi vous répondrais la
réponse est oui ou non c'est pas
compliqué non c'est pas c'est pas des
sujets aussi sa voix 6 mai pour la
victoire
s'il vous plaît vous proposant que paix
en tant que père a d'abord ma liberté ya
ma liberté surveillée at war et je vais
y arriver vos enfants pour qu'ils
puissent aller à l'école ils doivent
être injectés dans la politique
aujourd'hui vos enfants qui sont
scolarisés et ils ont les onze vaccins
dans le bras et veut attaquer mais vous
avez rendu l'année de soi vous sortez du
circuit scolaire ou encore en tout le
monde en même temps mort dans l'âme dans
sortait du circuit scolaire vos enfants
et vous les éduquer vous-même gérer une
vraie d'accord avec à la clé des règles
vous êtes
tout le monde choix et mon choix il est
personnel soit la réponse vacciner votre
fille à l'embêter tout le monde passion
pour la boxe
je n'ai jamais eu plaît messieurs ça
veut dire pour vous au niveau livre si
je comprends bien votre raisonnement que
si on en venait à dire qu'il y ait qui
on ait besoin d'une vaccination
obligatoire pour vous automatiquement ça
inclut aussi inclure dans la dent là
dedans la lignée mais les enfants c'est
logique puisque là le gouvernement vient
d'annoncer qu'à partir du mois de
janvier les enfants à partir de 5 ans
rentrait dans le cadre de vacciner au
libre choix des parents pour l'instant
au libre choix des parents pour
l'instant mais comme au libre choix de
tous les citoyens à partir du moment
qu'on amènera ses de vaccination
obligatoire ça voudra dire sera tous les
mois
ils seront obligés de vacciner leurs
enfants à partir de 5 ans et monsieur
est d'accord avec certaines actions dia
temps monsieur n'zi berankis geste est
une chose à l'affronter
sujet en juin et si et si demain ces
pandémies s éteint ce que nous
souhaitons tous à ce ticket ghost rider
c'est que chacun va reprendre sa vie
parce qu'on aille mais elle est
franchement elle et moi j'aime la vie
j'aime la vie et vous au fonds bain vous
avez faire causer un peu disparaître et
c'est tant mieux alors
dans la têt lunaire nancy j'ai déjà
mangé rebrodée nièce de téléphone que
vous attaquez régulièrement vous vous
êtes éloigné du roi où vous vous êtes et
léonie de l'ascenseur social qui sont
les vraies revendications partagées mais
je me la mets là et tu attends
je suis obligé de venir fille
c'est bon
s'éloigne du sujet les amis des livres
sur hitler
je ne peux pas bien vous dire comme non
mais
j'ai douze tomes je dis stop là vous
êtes entre je dis que je mets dans le 2e
acte dans le doute la maîtresse alors je
vous ai dit là vous êtes en train de
vous écarter du sujet on est en train de
parler de la vaccination soit
obligatoire ge on n'est pas en train de
parler de jérôme rodriguez et autres ce
sera un autre sujet pour l'instant sur
la vaccination obligatoire au livre je
parle on dirait mon fils jamal parler
sur la vaccination obligatoire je vais
faire un petit tour de table de mes
camarades pour savoir s'ils sont
d'accord avec l'un ou avec l'autre je
vais démarrer pas paris ça tient alors
oui alors je ne comprends pas tant de
violence de part et d'autre ça me gave
je ne comprends pas comment à partir de
même chiffre on arrive à dire des choses
diamétralement opposées moi je me
souviens des médecins qui étaient là
l'autre jour qui n'étaient pas du même
avis mais qu'ils étaient tous d'accord
sur le fait que ce qui était pour
l'instant à l'hôpital étaient surtout
des gens non vaccinés donc moi puisque
c'est paris contre paris je fais le pari
de la vaccination et si elle est
obligatoire est en vie elle est
obligatoire siona un nom
je ne sais qui n'est pas d'accord avec
la belle pas du tout d'accord je ne
comprends pas comment on peut imposer un
vaccin qui ne protège pas entièrement
contre un virus dans le vaccin comme
tous les ballons avec lesquels on a du
recul pourrait n'être qu'une
on est libre on est libre de faire sans
injecter ce qu'on veut dans notre île
géraldine juste on a un peu riant je me
permets je finis on a un mario qui
s'appelle omikron on sait même pas s'il
va résister le débat c'est l'accès au
vaccin pourquoi il est tout à fait
contents tous les riches ils ont des
variants attendent à commercy circuler
des russes à tout le monde en même temps
c'est vrai on est 80 7% et
médine sans être une maille à tola de la
vaccination elle serait que normalement
je devrais vous dire azille ayatollahs
la ya eu vol alors en usage à midi il me
semble qu'on en parle ici sur ce plateau
depuis deux ans on nous a jamais dit que
c'était la solution idéale mais la
solution miracle non jamais de la vie
enfin on nous a toujours dit ce qu on
pourrait avoir la codi un frein on nous
a dit juste que ça permettait de pas
emboliser l'erea d'éviter les formes
graves et c'est tout ce qu'on nous ait
qu'on pourrait revivre bah oui mais
hélas de confinement nous parle de
réflexion nous franchement vous exagérez
est-ce qu'on revit pas bah c'est cette
émission les gi public mais oui mon rôle
de cinquième banque au restaurant mais
on est quand même et on est quand même
beaucoup mieux qu'à deux ans qu'il
avait oublié
alors moi je suis pour la vaccination
obligatoire déjà des plus de 60 ans
maintenant laissez les vivre
c'est pas vieux soixante ans
[Rires]
la motivation des personnes des leurs
est actuellement de 60 cents mille
personnes de plus de 80 ans qui ne sont
pas vaccinés bah moi je trouve que c'est
pas normal donc lancé bout pour les
jeunes ont choisi des gens en priorit
obligatoire pour amy absolument d'accord
si le vaccin à les limites empêcher la
transmission du virus on se dirait c'est
pas une décision qui vous incombent
personnellement vous protéger la société
à vous protéger parce que ça m'empêche
pas la trouver endormie sur 1500 ça
permet de transmettre de façon
les neuf fois moins citez moi
transmettez autant le vernet variant il
se transmet ou tu en voilà donc si
c'était au protéger les autres on
protège en fait que ce soit des formes
graves la personne qui veut pas se faire
vacciner c'est une décision qui lui
prend il il choisi de risquer
sur
pourrir les nouveaux quotas mais pas ma
fille est en médecine donc je vous
remercie le bel effort mais pourquoi je
pas médecin
mais je suis un fils ont été mis son
livre en ligne quand même parce que là
on parle de plan blanc je vous entends
parler de plan blanc vient on a suspendu
nous soignons en pleine pandémie mais
bravo le gouvernement on a fermé des
vies en pleine pandémie mais bravo le
gouvernement on a fermé des hôpitaux en
pleine pandémie mais bravo le
gouvernement mais on voit qu'il est là
pour la santé des français on sait quand
et où
l'annoncé qu'en pour la prise en détail
des centristes stéphane rousseau s'est
su gérer son sérieux on parle de vie
sociale de nos salariés on parle de la
vie là le public ici présent on parle
des théâtres on parle de zones où la
france longtemps mais arrêtez de faire
dans le pathos nos enfin le jeu super et
j'ai envie vous c'est j'ai envie de
gérer mes enfants comme moi je le décide
si votre place je vais dans son
hypothèse si l'obligation vaccinale se
met en place qui n'est pas formellement
l'ordre des zooms a dit hall inhérents à
l'ordre du jour y ce qui n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour en place et le sujet les
oreilles dans son hypothèse est dans son
sens j'ai le ch en tant que père de
refuser
il y annonce vaccins obligatoires les
parents ont le choix de ne pas les
vacciner mais dans ce cas là
vous plaindre donne la parole c'est
aussi ce qui vaut pour ici sont les
fidèles suppôts du nouveau dictateur
manifold
s'il vous plaît les amis je vais vous
dire un truc
stéphane stéphane gil tout le monde je
vous dire un truc pour les
téléspectateurs qui vous regarde c'est
inaudible même ici sur le plateau ils
entendent pas ce que vous dites donc
vous argument tombe à l'eau donc les uns
après les autres j'ai l'impression
d'être une maîtresse d'école m'épuiser
gilles à la dictature c'est quoi la
dictature c'est de séparer les citoyens
en deux et là on veut séparer les
citoyens en deux les bons citoyens
vacciner les mauvais citoyens non
vaccinés ça marche pas comme ça en
viennent à se
vacciner valérie sinon nous nous sommes
déplacés
démocratie monsieur gilles verdez la
mesure ne fait pas partie après de votre
démonstration vous qui avez parlé d'
angélisme et dans la mesure la laisser
dans les médias est arrivé lorsque vous
avez me traiter de suppôt franchement
n'est pas à la hauteur de ce qui se
passe et quand vous faites votre vote
vous excès sur la fracture de la société
d'un côté les vaccinés et non non c'est
juste je vous dis juste j'en ai
ras-le-bol de lapine la sanction
collective j'en ai marre que
collectivement nous avons fait un choix
à 87% de se faire vacciner ça suffit la
punition collective c'est juste ça je
vous dis je dis pas d'un côté il ya les
uns et les autres je vous dis je n'ai
pas envie d'être puni parce que olivier
a fait le choix de ne pas se vacciner je
n'ai pas envie que le public s'est
laissé venir
parce que sur monsieur comme 17 % des
gens ont fait ce choix là tu vois que je
ne m'étais pas venu pour jouer parce que
13 % de l'action de la population ont
fait ce choix des mots creux je rejoins
et à nos très chers amis il ya eu la
bonne mesure et pour les amis une
conclusion